other big news for the David Pakman show
I love having positive news lately
because 2017 has had a lot of really
really bad news the big news is that the
david pakman show podcast is now on
spotify if you go to spotify either
mobile or desktop and search for the
david pakman show you will find the
david pakman show podcast really big
deal Spotify was initially mostly just
music it has grown to include podcasts
it is becoming a major podcast platform
and not everybody can just put their
podcast on Spotify we were actually
invited to put the David Pakman show on
Spotify and we are now on iTunes I Heart
Radio stitcher and Spotify and you can
follow us there really really great
stuff so I'm excited about this I
actually I love it when we get on a
platform I use and I use Spotify all the
time when I'm at the gym I'm listening
to music and podcasts on Spotify and
very very exciting so that's available
and also as I mentioned yesterday steam
it okay you can support the show merely
by uploading our content and you can
make some money yourselves by going to
steam it com that's ste MIT dot-com
create an account takes a couple days
for it to be verified but don't get put
off by that and then follow us
steam it comm slash at david pakman @
sign david pakman and just buy up voting
our content you will be supporting the
work we do so really good stuff it's
good to have good news because between d
monetization on youtube and the the
destruction as i call it
the elimination of our amazon affiliate
link and all of this different stuff
it's nice to have some wins yeah towards
the end of the year we like to keep it
light you know with the Jenga segment
yeah male this is great news as well yes
and by the way Pat has already committed
to buying a hundred and fifty thousand
david pakman show calendars we are not
going to be including those numbers
towards the goal because we it's great
that you're picking up all these
calendars but really the idea is for the
audience to buy as many as possible just
leave them all for myself I know it will
listen we can the great thing is we can
get as many calendars as we need be
we have a print supply shop that has
unlimited resources so if everybody
wants a calendar they can get it and
that's another thing i mentioned david
pakman.com slash calendar 1/8 to get the
2018 calendar